oui monsieur al wassat qu'on la cote
il se trompe l'oeil à j'ai un collègue
nous reprenons la séance l'ordre du jour
appelle un point avec leurs
représentants chargée de la politique
extérieure de sécurité il va lire ses
déclarations concernant sa visite en
russie et la répression contre les
manifestants et l'opposition
j'aimerais attirer l'attention sur le
fait que dans ce débat il n'y aura pas
de carton bleu il n'y aura pas de
questions posées à la volée j'aimerais
également vous dire qu'il va y avoir des
prises de parole à distance depuis les
bureaux de liaison du parlement des
verts dans les différents états membres
je donne maintenant la parole à monsieur
borel il faut en prime
[Musique]
mais je plains les présidences chers
députés du parlement européen
la russie et l'union européenne les
relations entre les deux on vraiment
fait 360 degrés depuis la charte de
paris
cette charte était l'équivalent de ce
qu'on appelle un tournant de l'histoire
après la chute du mur de berlin
la vision d'un espace commun de lisbonne
à vladivostok ne s'est jamais
matérialisé et la russie il n'a pas tenu
les attentes à savoir devenir une
démocratie moderne me nous sommes déçus
et la confiance ne règne plus entre
l'union européenne et la russie
beaucoup y des piliers qui font des nos
relations ont disparu est situé
l'ukraine le sud du caucase
la transnistrie en moldavie tout cela
exacerbe les tensions entre lieux et la
russie n'oublions pas également la
biélorussie les relations économiques
russes et européennes ont été fortement
mise à mal par les sanctions
la fourniture d'énergie qui pendant des
années ont été la colonne vertébrale de
nos liens vont être mis à mal par le
verdissement de l'économie mondiale nous
pourrons tirer ses conclusions pendant
notre des bars le dialogue politique est
dans l'impasse depuis le conflit en
ukraine
2014 depuis l'économie russe est à la
baisse elle a entraîné une chute de 30%
du pib par habitant et mellila le climat
politique ne cesse de se détériorer et
de lise et la bande d'aigris et puis il
ya la sphère navalni c'est dans ce
contexte que j'ai décidé de me rendre à
moscou la semaine dernière
l'objectif de ma visite était double
tout d'abord regarder et veut rencontrer
les homologue russe pour confronter la
position européenne sur les droits de
l'homme la liberté politique et la
situation d'alexei navalni c'est ce que
j'ai fait ils n'ont pas apprécié la
sphère alexeï navalni était au centre de
mes discussions avec le ministre lavrov
ensuite dans le cadre des préparations
des discussions sur le prochain conseil
prévu en mars sur les relations avec la
russie
je voulais voir si les autorités russes
étaient intéressés dans une tentative
véritable de renverser la tendance
négative de nos relations et saisir
l'opportunité pour avoir un dialogue
plus constructif
la réponse a été très clair non ils ne
sont pas intéressés
c'est nous continuons à aborder les
questions politiques et les droits de
l'homme
si ces questions figurent encore dans le
paquet ces questions sont inscrits dans
notre adn et nous ne pouvons nous taire
ma visite inclut et des consultations
avec le ministre affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov également des réunions
avec les ong les think tanks et des
représentants des industries européennes
des journalistes également des
ambassadeurs des pays de l'union
européenne j'ai rendu hommage à boris
nemtsov qui a été assassiné il ya six
ans maintenant qui a été abattue sur un
pont près du kremlin
cet assassinat terrible n'a jamais été
élucidé c'était un avant goût tout ce
que nous voyons aujourd'hui ma visite
s'est déroulée dans un contexte
particulièrement tendu et cette visite
dans représentait bien évidemment un
risque
j'ai décidé de prendre ce risque je les
fais d'une part parce que nous
condamnons la manière dont la sphère
navalni est gérée et d'autre part cela
me permettait également d'évaluer de mes
propres yeux les défis de nos relations
avec la russie
je ne me faisais pas d'illusion avant ma
visite
je suis encore plus inquiet après m'être
rendu sur place
alors qu'elle tirait comme enseignement
de cette visite tout d'abord le
gouvernement russe
est en train d'emprunter un chemin
particulièrement autoritaire ce qui est
inquiétant la liberté d'expression le
les la société civile n'a plus de place
quasiment pour plus de place pour une
alternative démocratique les autorités
russes ont montré dans la sphère navalni
qu'ils sont sans pitié
en effet la structure du pouvoir actuel
en russie
je parle de structures du pouvoir et en
russie et non pas de russie parce que
pour moi la russie ce sont les citoyens
russes le la structure du pouvoir est
fait d'un des co d'intérêt économique de
contrôle politique et il n'y a pas de
place pour des tas de droit démocratique
il y à une répression forte en cas de
tentative de débat autour des droits de
l'homme et des valeurs démocratiques
parce que pour eux c'est une menace
existentielle
ensuite ma visite a confirmé autre chose
la tendance à long terme où nous voyons
que la russie est déconnecté de l'europe
il n'y a quasiment aucun progrès
concernant les conflits dans notre
voisinage proche
ils sont déconnectés parce qu'il
considère que notre système démocratique
et libérale est une menace existentielle
qui pèsent sur leur pays lors des
discussions avec le ministre lavrov
nos discussions était agitée puisque
j'ai demandé la libération immédiate et
inconditionnelle d'alexei navalni et
j'ai demandé une enquête concernant la
tentative d'assassinât dont il a fait
l'objet
je lui ai demandé également de pouvoir
rencontrer alexeï navalni ils m'ont dit
d'aller au tribunal et
un membre de la délégation a pu
rencontrer l'avocat d'alexei navalni
pendant ma visite et nous allons rester
en contact avec son équipe pour leur
signifier notre soutient nous avons
également discuté de questions affaires
étrangères j'ai insisté sur le fait
qu'il fallait vraiment appliquer
pleinement l'accord de minsk il fallait
pleinement respecter l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine il fallait
également entendre l'appel des citoyens
biélorusses qui demandent de pouvoir
choisir librement leur président
cependant sur certaines questions
notamment sur l'accord iranien pour le
nucléaire nous avons pu améliorer la
collaboration
je le soutiens au dialogue
israël palestine également là nous
pourrions améliorer notre collaboration
mais nous n'avons pas pu discuter plus
en détail de ces sujets compte tenu de
la rapidité de ma visite
lors de cette visite quelque chose m'est
apparu assez clairement les homologues
russes n'ont pas l'intention de
poursuivre le dialogue si nous
continuons à nous attacher aux droits de
l'homme et à la liberté d'expression sur
des allégations non fondées
certains diplomates ont été arrêtés il
n'y a pas eu d'annoncé de la part des
russes
nous l'avons appris par les réseaux je
pense que c'était un message très clair
la réunion était terminée j'ai demandé
au ministre lavrov de revoir sa décision
et le soir
j'ai fait une annonce concernant cet
incident alors permettez moi maintenant
d'en venir aux conclusions que j'ai tiré
de cette visite
je suis particulièrement inquiet quant
aux perspectives et aux choix
stratégiques géostratégiques des
autorités russes pour la société russe
également nous sommes à un carrefour
dans nos relations avec la russie et les
choix que nous allons faire auront un
impact sur les dynamiques
internationales des 10 2 de ce siècle
est ce que nous voulons aller vers un
modèle plus polarisé il tout à part nous
allons discuter de ces questions
le 22 février au conseil européen
ensuite en mars nous aurions des
orientations sur la marche à suivre et
les états membres devront décider des
prochaines étapes à suivre
mais en effet il serait bon d'inclure
des sanctions et je ferai des
propositions concrètes faisant usage du
droit d'initiative qui est le mien en
tant que haut représentant ces efforts
devraient inclure également une
combinaison entre des actions visant à
lutter contre la désinformation les
cyber attaques et autres défis hybride
deuxièmement en parallèle malgré les
difficultés il est primordial de
permettre une implication officielle
lorsque c'est dans notre intérêt
la russie est notre principal voisins
nous devons trouver un modus vivendi
pour éviter une confrontation permanente
et troisièmement mais pas des moindres
nous devons continuer à être en contact
avec la société russe les russes la
russie est un pays européen et une
grande partie des citoyens européens
souhaitent maintenir des liens forts
avec l'union européenne
ils ont des aspirations démocratiques
véritable nous ne devons pas leur
tourner le dos le pouvoir russe soit se
désengager de l'europe se déconnecter de
l'europe mais nous ne nous vont pas nous
déconnecter des citoyens russes de la
société civile russe
nous devons trouver un moyen de
progresser sur ces questions et ainsi
nous pourrons préserver notre unité et
notre détermination sans unité il n'y
aura pas de détermination et sans cela
nous ne pourrons pas trouvé de bonnes
politiques
la russie a tenté de nous diviser
il souhaite nous diviser ils n'ont pas
réussi à le faire sur les questions
ukrainienne sur les questions les droits
de l'homme ils n'ont pas réussi à nous
diviser
l'objectif est apparu clairement durant
ma visite et nous ne devons pas tomber
dans leur piège
pour ma part j'ai re député vice
présidente
je vais continuer à défendre le du débat
je vais les regarder droit dans les yeux
notamment sur les questions sensibles
défendre les droits d'alexei navalni à
moscou son procès était en cours on m'a
empêché de le voir
cela montre que la politique étrangère
ce n'est pas juste
rédiger des communiqués de presse de mon
bureau au berlaymont
il est important de faire preuve de
notre inquiétude en personne au bon
moment et au bon endroit
j'espère que ce débat va alimenter les
discussions qui auront lieu au conseil
et j'ai hâte de poursuivre la gestion de
nos relations avec la russie merci
quito que sept corps qu'elle est et de
ce fait sk pourrait voir racheter aia
merci merci pour cette contribution
maintenant c'est le tour des groupes
politiques
je vais tout d'abord donné la parole à
monsieur galère pour le groupe et je
vous en prie
quito sports oms merci donc on sortait
cher collègue monsieur le haut
représentant votre voyage à moscou a
permis de bien comprendre la situation
et de dissiper les illusions que nous
nourrissions votre visite cette
conférence de presse
outrageuse à susciter vraiment la colère
ici dans cette enceinte monsieur lavrov
a eu un comportement tout à fait
inacceptable certes vous avez mis sur la
table certains points importants la
demande de libération d'alexis les
vanniers l'agression des pays voisins
également mais est ce que on ne devait
pas s'attendre à ce que lavrov s'attaque
à l'union européenne il aurait été
adéquat de répondre et de réfuter les
mots de lavera sur la catalogne la
lettonie cuba c'est la russie qui est
l'agresseur en ukraine et ailleurs ce
n'est pas nous
les autorités russes se font assassiner
les gens sur leur territoire ce n'est
pas nous les choses sont maintenant
limpide alors il ne faut plus se bercer
d'illusions je crois que les choses sont
claires la russie ne souhaite pas le
dialogue et les dirigeants
russes souhaitent nous diviser nous
européens nous devons faire preuve
d'unité nous devons défendre nos
intérêts nous demandons message clair
d'unités de détermination du conseil de
deux dirigeants il nous espérons que les
états membres vont pouvoir invoquer
l'acte magnitski vous en avez parlé
merci enfin que tous les juges et les
procureurs puissent jouer leur rôle et
que on est des résultats un peu plus
convaincant alors il faut s'attaquer aux
personnes qui profitent de la situation
il faut leur interdire l'accès à l'union
européenne
il faut lutter contre leurs opérations
de blanchiment dans nos pays européens
il faut que notre coopération soit
entière
merci qui merci chaque les galères cela
ne m'atteint la parole pour le groupe
s&d un autre que les quais tpir et
depuis l'ère merci à quoi nous avons
assisté dans lequel la vallée c'est un
kafka en 2021
après avoir a failli le tuer il fallait
le mettre hors jeu
navalni a mis le doigt où ça fait mal
les rues sales ont assez de la capte
grassi de poutine alors que les gens
lambda souffre de difficultés
économiques
moscou a utilisé de façon visible la
visite représentant borel pour
l'humilier et offenses l union
européenne a expulsé trois diplomates
pendant sa visite et lavrov a dit que
l'union européenne est un partenaire non
fiables alors que la russie fait tout
pour nous diviser mais incriminé
monsieur borel pour cela
est-ce que la même chose ne se serait
pas passé si l'union européenne avait
une position plus fort jusqu'ici le
conseil n'a pas édicté de sanctions
fortes contre la russie après la
tentative d'assassinât contre nos
vallées or banal éviter que l'union
européenne puisse rendre un communiqué
comment il ya eu l'émission de
passeports et de permis de séjour par
les autorités chypriotes à des
responsables russes monsieur macron a
rappelé qu'il souhaitait rompre les
discussions avec moscou et il y a eu une
reprise des discussions sur le north
stream 2 par la russie avec le soutien
de madame merkel
il faut une stratégie par l'apaisement
au vu des défis posés par la russie en
termes de sécurité européenne ce qui
signifie que le conseil devra avoir des
sanctions claires et dure vis-à-vis de
poutine et de ceux qui les aident et je
pense que monsieur bourrel a tiré les
mêmes conclusions merci merci merci que
le pire est maintenant pour le groupe
renault